and the best person to give an answer to
this question I want him to react we
just heard the news of our brother Habib
so alike former professional fighter
also teammate for khabib and now we just
heard the news I heard actually from Joe
Rogan you know let's check out this clip
real quick but if you guys don't know
what I'm talking about and now he just
got out I think he's decided to retire
completely from mixed martial arts
coaching and everything very religious
did you see the clip with uh Joe Rogan
or how did you hear the news you heard
the news is your former teammates you
know I mean there's a lot of the
internet yeah okay what's your so before
we're going to show one self-defense
move since I got Ali catokov in the
house so tell me what's your reaction
now I'm a teammate with Habib and now
you're hearing this and then we did that
show way way back when about your story
why you left professional fighting for
all those years what's your reaction he
gave up coaching everything that's what
he say inshallah you know may Allah him
but yeah he'd give up everything he left
you know first he leave the fighting is
a professional fighter now he'll leave
it all he just walk away as a coach as
well so it's good alhamdulillah so
let's get into this move now that can
help you guys very common what will
happen on the streets is you'll see this
where the person grabs your head and a
lot of times they'll even turn now you
being an experienced the guy will turn
his head the wrong way come over here
turn his head this way away and next you
know you're in a choke ah and I've seen
people like get choked out here and you
know if it holds too long this guy's
Holding On For Life he's not letting go
and now he's choking the guy he's
turning the wrong way into the choke and
that's it the guy's brain dead all right
but let's go ahead one common Escape
here look one common hold he's gonna
grab boom whoever want to turn my head
this way I want to turn around at any
time if he throws a punch I have to be
ready to
make sure I control the arm that can hit
my face but this particular case he's
holding on tight I'm going to ground
back
oh
from here I take him down he's still
holding on I'm gonna step over
make the frame break his grip and then
from here I can strike or I can take the
arm oh
and finish here
thank you my brother always good seeing
you here oh yeah but you know what why
don't we finish there we got a dagestani
world champion Olympic uh Olympic level
wrestler who uh we'll get a double treat
will show a nice takedown go ahead
[Music]
okay
single to double
it's good okay
beautiful beautiful got a double treat
here only on the D show thank you what's
your name introduce yourself you're from
from Dagestan huh
and our brother Saeed he's from Satya
also salaam Lincoln Brothers peace be
with you
[Music]
we're here with uh
yeah all right guys so we signed
everything here
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
Muslims around here it's it's pretty
huge and uh like this the place the
location that you opened in basically
it's far further south from the other
other big massages and everyone I know a
lot of people that I used to I come my
cousin lives nine minutes from here
another Uncle of mine lives about five
to ten minutes from here this area yeah
opened up in an area that it's much
needed and this size yeah I mean this
you know the center this Center is much
needed for this area and the idea of
this Center is needed for the whole
stick because we don't have anything
like that in the whole state that was
censor where it's going to basically
nurture and basically educate and it's
gonna basically spread Islam